toi merci tu as du mal à ce voyage dont
une chante
oui ça demande un effort plus orienté
les que quand scène parce que c'est vrai
que la télévision c'est pas un élément
que je me sens particulièrement à l'aise
confie est passé par le manque
d'habitude peut-être parce que j'ai pas
peut-être n'ont plus envie de rentrer
totalement dedans je sais pas mais mais
mais il ya une espèce de retenue qui
fait que d'adresser les sourires la
caméra c'est un peu étrange c'est un
métier dix mois les belles la melonite
n'arrête pas de faire les belles
mélodies et fort prix maintenant fort je
suis musicien quoi principalement donc
faut bien que je fasse remarquer d'une
manière ou d'une autre mais tf1 l'album
ça fait double vie en 88 suis là
s'appelle troubles c'est quand même le
client idéal pour double je ne sais quoi
le double jeu dans ta vie toi tu vis à
comment je crois que ça se met le plus
en plus quoi mais metz mais j'ai
toujours essayé malgré tout deux d'avoir
une représentation du chanteur et de
savoir faire la part des choses entre ce
que racontait le chanteur ce qu'il
évoquait et caetera et puis le moal
exactement comme un cadre supérieur
ça dépend des périodes en ce moment
c'est calme en ce moment c'est ce soir à
lens et de les années précédentes
comment tu fais pour pas dire j'ai un
bon et je ferai arrivants comme toi
on vieillit poche n'oubliez pas de venir
fêter dans le coeur joie